this diagram was super important to us
dear member we concluded using some
fancy user tomorrow serum and polar form
that if you are taking the roots of a
complex number or wherever it happens to
be on the complex plane and this year
zone this is the complicated then the
result all of the roots of that topic
something that you get you find it
arranged on the circumference of a
circle do you remember this idea right
so for example if I said to you what was
the one we looked at we looked at like
the sixth fruits and the fifth roots I
think of particular kinds of numbers
right so for example if I have if I have
one right and by the way we said one had
a special number do you remember what
the sorry especially name Rama was a
special name of one we called a unity so
his unity
he's the origin right if you wanted to
take say for example the seventh roots
of unity okay the first thing I want to
ask you how many seventh roots are of
unions there are seven four seven seven
we said that that has I am that has an
important idea that comes along with it
but on the little carrot algebra that if
you've got a polynomial and degree is
seven you're going to get exactly seven
complex solutions now where would they
be if this was the you tone okay let's
not label it just yet because I don't
want don't want this to be if this were
the unit circle where are these seven
how do you describe where these seven
roots are going to me where's the first
one was the first most obvious one it's
going to be at unity right because unity
is its own seventh root eighth root etc
so I'm gonna have one there okay where
the rest of the roots going to be how
would you verbally describe them like
without pointing in say negative one is
there gonna be one over here
what are you reckoning that's
interesting negative one is frequently
one of the roots of unity but only half
the time okay think about it negative
one is one of those square roots of
unity
okay but it's not one of a cube root in
do you remember what the cube roots of
unity well thank you member where they
are because when I start to position
them around the circumference what was
the UM like a bit all gonna be like over
here or they going to be done here there
was a particular geometric quality that
they had that helps us understand where
they are in relation to each other
session okay they're gonna be even in
the case of cube roots they're going to
be a to pile of three around this way
and there's a lot of the two pi on three
and then another two point three to get
you back okay that was it in the case of
cube roots obviously seventh roots are
not gonna be to plan through how far are
they going to be a part two PI over
seven right because you're gonna need to
space out seven of them right and now
I'm going to be here's the phrase I want
you to remember they want to be equally
spaced do you recall that okay so for
example here's one of the nice things
about it actually you know what let's
try oh if you were to put seven on here
okay what shape is that going to trace
out it's gonna trace out a heptagon if
you were to go all the way around okay
now to play on seven let's just drop
this down to PI and seven it's a bit
hard for us to grapple with this idea
because we've been so used to living in
the degrees well how many degrees is to
pilot seven oh my god I can calculate
this I don't want to get atom number
that's close we'll go at 51 that'll be
Chris enough okay so 51 degrees it's a
bad degree of sign can we just generally
put on two there I mean you can see if
that's 19 then 45 is going to be here 45
quite easy to spot visually so I'm
guessing 51 is just a little bit extra
yeah do you agree that so let's put that
all on them okay so if we call that 51
degrees the next one's gonna be at 102
degrees ish right so 102
here's 19 right so a hundred two is
gonna be just past that do go do that
okay can you put these on with me can
you put the other we've got three
already put the other four
it's okay you don't have these
infrastructure to do that
okay I'm dumb I missed okay now the
first thing is eternal a minute you can
actually kind of visualize the heptagon
do you see where it is right there it
goes sort of going all the way around
okay so another way you could describe
this is that you're going to trace out
beyond the nth roots of a complex number
I'm going to trace out a regular n-gon
like a regular picture gone crazy only
have to go in the regular hexagon
whatever
this isn't this is an end gone right
that's like I'm not just making that up
by the way that's what it's no you can
see that there now I want you to do to
something else about these on these
routes do you see because of your way we
have spaced them out if I have if I give
these routes some names okay and I'm
gonna call this one instead one is there
to all the way around not only are they
evenly spaced from adjacent
routes as you go around right do you
notice they kind of come in pairs do you
notice that there's like this guy just
hanging out on his own but every other
one you may want to try this on every
other one is paired up right for example
said to tell me six seven is that threes
paired with their seats and is it for is
pl-please in five when I put them in
those pairs what's the relationship but
we chose pairs they're complex
conjugates spot that right so for
example and this is what likely to draw
on here right you can draw a dotted line
down here and you can see this is X plus
I Y and X minus iy do you see it is a
weight X plus iy x let's draw this line
minus iy and this
anyway X plus iy and x-rays I watched so
you've got these conjugate pairs in
there that's kind of cool
another way you can think about
conjugate pairs is not just in
rectangular form we know that these guys
these guys are how you would write
conjugate pairs in a in rectangular form
how do you write conjugate pairs in
polar form
do you remember I'll give you a clue we
know that could pull form stunts like
that right
but what you've got here is a pair and
you're going to rotate to two different
spots right so in fact to try and put
both of these together right I'm going
to have one which goes in the
anti-clockwise direction that's the
normal in the direction I measure it so
there goes the plus theta to go plus
theta two got to Z 2 right like let's
put them in how do i what angle do i
rotate through to get to the conjugate
pair yeah I'm gonna go down here to
negative theta because I'm going in the
clockwise direction you see then so this
is going to plus minus feet up and
you've got I sine of plus minus theta
okay so this is the way you write
conjugate pairs in rectangular form this
is the way you wrap them in polar form
okay oh quickly by the way you notice
the X's the real part they should be the
same number right because of course cos
theta and caused negative it up think
about what kind of option is cause it's
a it's an even function right he's
symmetrical about the X and the y-axis
so therefore cos theta can take your
feet up there the same number yeah you
with me okay and this is what we focused
on last time I will just quickly mention
a name for you because as I've been
mentioning names these are important
names give you power and understanding
concepts how you just noticed that these
come up in pairs
okay it actually hasn't named this idea
we're not going to do with it follow me
now because you really need all the bits
and pieces and polynomials but you've
only done a little bit on but this is
called the complex conjugate root
theorem the complex conjugate cleaner of
states you don't need to worry about
getting this formal definition now but I
want you to hear it
is that all of these we could say
they're the seventh roots of unity right
the seventh root of e the cemeteries of
unity are all the solutions to a
particular polynomial what polynomial of
a decisions what polynomial could I
write such if you solve that you get
these seven I'm gonna go in there but
that's fine
save ^ 7 it should equal 1 right because
the whole point of being a 7th root
right is that if you raise it about 7
and you shouldn't get one do you hear
that
so the polynomial that this corresponds
to is this guy is polynomial here okay
now in fact if you want any polynomial
you like right so long as these
coefficients are real the coefficient to
run a negative 1 in this case and a
whole bunch of zeros in between I don't
have any 10 to the 6
this n to the 5 etc but so long as all
coefficients are real
then every single solution you get will
have a pair it will always have a pair
like this okay and the pair will be
complex conjugates okay
in fact you already knew this you
already knew this think about them
think about your quadratic right you
know how we started we can take on dice
that's how we introduce in imaginary
numbers when you have a look at a
quadratic which isn't supposed to have
roots right like x squared plus X plus 1
that has no real roots okay but all the
coefficients are real
so therefore the solutions to these guys
whatever they happen to be they're going
to be complex conjugates of one another
there's a really fancy proof for it but
that will have to wait for another time